unser Thema heute ist ein echter
Aufreger angegriffene Feuerwehrleute
Gewalt in Neukölln und anderswo in der
Republik und eine Debatte die in
kürzester Zeit total polarisiert und
giftig geworden ist wie kommt es dass
die Diskussion immer so eskaliert wenn
Migranten an Straftaten beteiligt sind
willkommen zu einem inside-politics über
Rassismus Vertuschung und die mühsame
Suche nach echten Lösung
ist schon ein bisschen her aber der
Rauch der Silvesternacht verzieht sich
nur langsam wir haben in der
Zwischenzeit versucht einen möglichst
umfassendes Lagebild zu erstellen die
Bilder von der Silvesternacht junge
Männer die marodieren durch
Berlin-Neukölln ziehen mit
Schreckschusspistolen auf Leute Zielen
Busstationen verwüsten Feuerwehrwagen
attackieren die Einsatzkräfte die
teilweise sogar als freiwillige ihren
Silvesterabend dafür geopfert haben um
anderen zu helfen und für Sicherheit zu
sorgen sind sichtlich geschockt
angesichts einer wie sie sagen neuen
Qualität von Gewalt gegen Polizei und
Feuerwehr das was man als Einsatzkraft
erleben musste war einfach brutal also
man wurde beschossen und man wurde
beleidigt wir wurden in einen Hinterhalt
gelockt 15 Feuerwehrleute und 37
Polizistinnen wurden verletzt selbst
gestandene Feuerwehrmänner kurz vor der
Pensionierung hätten Angst gehabt sagt
der Leiter der Berliner Feuerwehr wenn
die Regierende Bürgermeisterin sagt so
ein Silvester darf es nicht noch einmal
geben kann man ihr nur zustimmen das
sind die Leute in Neukölln übrigens auch
so es war nicht schön also als ich heute
morgen den nächsten Tag der Bus gesehen
habe war ich entsetzt
auch gesagt dass das geht zu weit wie
Sie wissen die Jugendliche die haben
auch die Grenzen verloren die wissen
nicht mehr wo die ganzen sind die
bundesinnenministerin nennt sie Feser
kündigt schnell harte Strafen an
rechtlich geht das das Strafmaß für
Angriffe auf Einsatzkräfte wurde schon
2017 erhöht bis zu fünf Jahre Gefängnis
stehen und darauf sehr abschreckend
wirkt es aber nicht die Angriffe auf
Polizeivollzugsbeamter etwa stiegen in
den vergangenen Jahren kontinuierlich an
allein in Berlin waren es im Jahr 2022
8400 die Täter sind bundesweit übrigens
zu 70% deutsche Staatsbürger der
nordrhein-westfälische Innenminister
Royal konzentriert sich in seiner
Analyse der Silvesternacht dann auch
eher auf das Alter der ganz überwiegend
männlichen Täter seit Jahren weiß ich
darauf hin dass wir ein Problem in den
großstädtischen Strukturen haben von
Gruppen junger Männer oft auch mit
Migrationshintergrund aber nicht nur und
insofern kann ich uns nur raten wir
müssen damit differenziert umgehen die
ganz von Autorität die Akzeptanz von
staatlicher Institution das akzeptieren
dass es Regeln in einem System von
Gesellschaft geben muss nachdem man sich
richten muss das ist nicht sehr weit
verbreitet übrigens nicht nur bei denen
die jetzt auf der Straße mit Böllern
schießen sondern auch bei denen die
irgendwo anders mit Steinen schmeißen
was soll jetzt also passieren Faser will
dass man für Schreckschusspistolen
künftig einen Waffenschein benötigt und
alle halbautomatischen Waffen will sie
sowieso verbieten von viel geforderten
böllerverbot hält sie nicht und dann
obwohl das schon seit Tagen gesagt wurde
und auch Nancy fazer ist schon
getwittert hatte sagte sie es auch noch
mal so als ob es noch nicht gesagt
worden sei das waren überwiegend Täter
mit Migrationshintergrund das muss man
auch ansprechen man muss auf der anderen
Seite aber auch ansprechen dass das
natürlich für die Bevölkerung in den
Brennpunkten gerade auch diejenigen
treffen die Migrationshintergrund haben
die sind auch gleichermaßen Opfer haha
viele der Täter haben also
Migrationshintergrund in Köln ist das
unter jungen Männern eher normal dort
ist das nämlich bei im zweiten so dass
er Migrationshintergrund hat in ganz
Deutschland hat übrigens mehr als jeder
vierte Mensch Migrationsgeschichte unter
jungen Leuten mindestens jeder dritte
alle sagten und schrieben davon trotzdem
warf die AFD und so mancher im Netz der
Politik und den Medien weiter
Vertuschung vor tun es übrigens immer
noch apropos vertuschen denn zwischen
will bei fast einem Drittel aller
Fernsehbeiträge über Gewaltkriminalität
die Herkunft des Tatverdächtigen erwähnt
über proportional häufig wenn dieser ein
Ausländer ist dass sich daraus ergebende
Bild ist stark verzerrend so sagt eine
Studie des Mediendienstes Integration
die Polizei ermittelt in den letzten
Jahren immer etwa doppelt so viele
Deutsche Gewalttäter wie nicht deutsche
im Fernseh berichten kommen aber auf
jeden erwähnten deutschen Straftäter 8
ausländische am 16 Januar gibt die
Polizei neue immer noch vorläufige
Zahlen zur Silvesternacht heraus danach
wurden bislang 39 Tatverdächtige im
Zusammenhang mit Angriffen auf
Einsatzkräfte ermittelt von diesen haben
14 die deutsche 15 eine ausländische und
zehn eine deutsche und eine andere
Staatsangehörigkeit die Tätergruppe
scheint für Neukölln ziemlich im Schnitt
zu liegen und dann stellt sich die Frage
warum muss man ihre Herkunft und die
ihrer Eltern oder Großeltern überhaupt
erwähnen wenn es darum geht was mit den
Tätern geschehen soll dann ist das doch
eine Info die völlig überflüssig ist das
sind Typen die hier leben die die
demokratischen Institutionen und ihre
Repräsentanten nicht respektieren Sachen
kaputt machen und Menschen angreifen sie
müssen bestraft werden ob sie
Migrationshintergrund haben oder nicht
muss für das Strafmaß egal sein aber
darum geht es offensichtlich nicht
Friedrich Merz hat sich vorgenommen die
AFD zu halbieren weit ist der
CDU-Vorsitzende damit bisher nicht
gekommen diese Debatte aber bietet gute
Möglichkeiten März sagt die gehören
nicht hierher nicht weil sie gewalttätig
sind sondern weil sie gewalttätig und
migrantisch sind die kleinen Paschas wir
haben es hier mit einem veritablen
Problem mangelnder Integration junge
Menschen zu tun überwiegend
Migrationshintergrund und von denen
überwiegend aus der arabischen Welt so
und dieser Staat darf sich dieses
Verhalten nicht bieten lassen dürfte der
Staat sich das denn von Leuten bieten
lassen die nicht aus der arabischen Welt
sind ich möchte Probleme beim
Zusammenleben unterschiedlicher
Nationalitäten wirklich nicht kleinreden
natürlich gibt es Herkunftsländer von
Migranten in denen Frauen oder
Minderheiten seines Juden Anhänger
anderer Glaubensrichtungen oder Menschen
mit nicht heterosexueller Orientierung
Rechte abgesprochen werden wenn solche
Positionen in Deutschland offen
vertreten werden muss der Staat und muss
die Gesellschaft dem klar entgegentreten
auf Feuerwehrleute loszugehen ist aber
auch in anderen Ländern kein anerkannter
Volkssport noch immer kennen wir keine
Details über die Täter von ihren Pässen
abgesehen es scheint aber sozusagen dass
selbst unter den nicht deutschen viele
dabei waren die hier aufgewachsen oder
auch hier geboren sind das sind Berliner
Kinder diese Kinder sind in Schulen
gegangen und haben trotzdem keinen
Respekt vor dem Start wie kann das sein
warum gelingt es unserem Start nicht
diesen Respekt einzufordern brauchen wir
eine Kita-Pflicht mehr Sozialarbeit
Anlaufstellen mehr
antirassismus-training der
Mehrheitsgesellschaft alles keine neuen
Ideen und alles zugegeben eher
langwierig im Netz gibt es viele die
haben schnellere Lösungsvorschläge
abriegeln zusammentreiben scharf
zurückschießen zeigen wer der Boss ist
das Thema entwickelt jedenfalls jede
Menge Eigendynamik die CSU nutzt es um
einmal mehr Berlin als Chaos statt
darzustellen ich glaube das solche
Exzesse wie wir es in Berlin erleben
woanders nicht in der gleichen Dimension
möglich sind
es gibt immer einzelne Chaoten aber in
Berlin scheint es ja ein gewisses System
zu haben der fdp-justizminister fordert
die Täter müssten ausgewiesen oder
abgeschoben werden klingt mag ich wird
aber nicht klappen denn wir erinnern uns
15 von ihnen haben eine ausländische
Staatsbürgerschaft sollten das Menschen
aus Kriegsgebieten sein Afghanistan und
Syrien etwa dann schiebt die
Bundesrepublik in diese Staaten nicht ab
und zwar nicht weil sie es nicht will im
Koalitionsvertrag steht ausdrücklich
dass man mehr Gefährder und Straftäter
rückführen will sondern weil es nicht
geht weil nämlich diese Staaten nicht
kooperieren und die Leute nicht
aufnehmen genauso wenig funktioniert das
versprochene schnelle Urteilen über die
Täter dafür fehlt es ein Personal an den
Gerichten und die Ermittlungen müssen
sorgfältig vonstatten gehen Monate werde
es dauern heißt es die Berliner CDU
hatten noch eine Idee sie will die
Vornamen der deutschen Tatverdächtigen
erfahren wozu nun ganz offensichtlich
wird vermutet dass die Täter eben nicht
Klaus und Jürgen heißen die
Integrationsbeauftragte des Bundes hat
sich dazu sehr deutlich geäußert diese
Aufteilung und Bürgerinnen und Bürger
erster und zweiter Klasse die geht in
eine völlig falsche Richtung das geht
überhaupt nicht und das sendet das
falsche Signal nämlich es ist egal was
ihr macht ihr werdet nie dazugehören den
Migrationshintergrund zu erwähnen macht
entweder Sinn weil man Stimmung machen
will oder aber wenn man verstehen nicht
entschuldigen will warum junge Männer an
Silvester Einsatzkräfte angreifen und
alles kurz und klein schlagen und wenn
man es verstehen will dann wird schnell
klar der Migrationshintergrund ist nur
ein Faktor und zwar einer der vor allem
die soziale Lage dieser Jugendlichen
definiert sucht man nach weiteren
Gründen die zu den Ausschreitungen
geführt haben können sondern Experten
folgende erstens die Pandemie lange gab
es zu wenig Sozialkontakte keine Schule
kaum Sozialarbeit die meisten
Jugendclubs waren geschlossen es fehlt
schlicht an Übung im sozialen
Miteinander zweitens beenkt der Wohnraum
der vor allem während der Pandemie zu
erhöhtem Stress geführt hat drittens
Silvester wurde als Gelegenheit genutzt
mal die Sau raus zu lassen das geböllere
so erklärt gewaltforscher Andreas Zick
versetze die Jugendlichen in einen
rauschartigen Zustand und dann kann man
die so entstandenen Bilder auch noch
sehr erfolgreich auf Social Media posten
und sich als Superheld fühlen viertens
und das ist ein grundlegendes Problem
kommt hinzu das ist in Neukölln die mit
Abstand höchste Arbeitslosigkeit in
Berlin gibt auch junge Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund kommen häufig aus
bildungsfernen Familien und haben wenig
Zukunftschancen 5 kommt hinzu Menschen
die aus Kriegsgebieten kommen haben oft
fundamental andere Erfahrungen gemacht
als die Mehrheit der deutschen
Bevölkerung der Kriminologe dr wahlburg
aus Münster erklärt was sie Gewalt
erfahren haben in ihren Herkunftsländern
auf der Flucht was dann ein Stück weit
gewaltrisiken auch noch beeinflussen
kann das sind hintergrundfaktoren die
das so ein bisschen mit erklären können
generell muss aber sagen natürlich auch
bei jungen Menschen mit
migrationsbezügen ist gewaltsames
Verhalten die Ausnahme
Jugendkriminalität insgesamt das sagt
Weilburg auch ist in den letzten Jahren
übrigens kontinuierlich zurückgegangen
so wann aber ist es stimmig geflüchtete
und hier geborene mit
Migrationshintergrund in einen Topf zu
werfen wenn es um ihre Erfahrungen in
der deutschen Gesellschaft geht
rassismuserfahrungen nämlich die
Sozialarbeiterin Songül chatin Kaya
betreut in ihrem Neuköllner Jugendclub
vor allem Kinder die ausländisch
Aussehen es verläuft kein einziger
Ausflug also sobald wir mehr als sechs
Jugendliche mit uns haben verläuft kein
einziger Ausflug ohne eine
rassismuserfahrung und die sind
teilweise vehement und stark wenn man
jeden Tag mit Rassismus konfrontiert ist
und wenn man jeden Tag abgelehnt wird
und wenn dann jeden Tag gesagt wird du
gehörst hier nicht dazu dann passiert
halt auch einfach eine trotz Reaktion
aus den Jugendlichen heraus aus dem Mund
des gewaltforschers klingt das dann so
wenn ich die Erfahrung mache ich komme
hier nicht weiter ich bin hier im Kiez
über den alle immer reden als
abgehängten Stadtteil als angehängte
Nachbarschaft dann bilden sich neue
Identitäten Migration hat mit neue
Identitätsbildung zu tun und wenn diese
neuen Identitäten
eine geringere Hemmschwelle für Gewalt
beinhalten dann haben wir
eine verpasste
Integrationspolitik dann haben wir
Integrationsprozesse die vielleicht
schief gelaufen sind das ist alles
überhaupt nicht neu so über
Migrationsgeschichte zu sprechen könnte
Sinn machen denn das sind alles
veränderliche Faktoren der
Migrationshintergrund kann eben nur der
Anfang der Debatte sein und nicht ihr
Ende es ist ein Fakt dass man als
ausländische Ausländer Mensch oder als
jemand mit einem nicht deutschen Namen
in unserem Land permanent mit Rassismus
konfrontiert wird das hat die
Integrationsbeauftragte
waren gerade erst in einem Bericht
festgehalten 90 Prozent der Deutschen
sagen darin es gibt in diesem Land
Rassismus das entschuldigt keine
Attacken auf Einsatzkräfte Randale oder
sonstiges schlechtes Benehmen aber es
erklärt warum die jungen Männer sich
benehmen als gehörten sie nicht dazu
weil ihn immer wieder vermittelt wird
dass sie nicht dazu gehören die ganze
Debatte zeigt meiner Ansicht nach vor
allem eins die Mehrheitsgesellschaft
kann sich nicht an den Fakt gewöhnen
dass Deutschland ein Einwanderungsland
ist immer wieder bricht sich in dieser
Diskussion der Gedanke Bahn ob es allein
unter deutschen ohne sichtbaren
Migrationshintergrund nicht alles viel
besser wäre dieser Haltung die auch in
der silvesterdebatte zu Tage tritt
begegnet Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund jeden Tag und
versperrt allen den Weg nach vorne auch
wenn sich viele wünschen dass alle ohne
deutschen Stammbaum das Land verlassen
es wird nicht passieren es gibt dafür
keine politische Mehrheit weil
Deutschland Einwanderer braucht
Friedrich Merz sagt 200.000 im Jahr der
Chef des BDI sagt 700.000 und die
potentiellen ausländischen Fachkräfte
werden sich die Silvester Debatte auch
sehr genau anschauen und sich überlegen
ob sie in ein Land ziehen wollen das mit
Menschen die nicht so sind wie sie so
umgeht man muss sich im Klaren darüber
sein dass das permanente herumreiten auf
Migrationshintergrund nur einem Zweck
dient der Spaltung alle anderen
friedliebenden Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund die den Staat und
seine Gesetze achten und die die der
Einsatzkräfte von Polizei Feuerwehr und
Lebensrettung respektieren sehen sich
seit Silvester einmal mehr in der
Defensive haben das Gefühl sie werden
mit noch mehr Argwohn beäugt als ohnehin
schon das hilft weder dem künftigen
Zusammenleben noch dem
Sicherheitsbedürfnis von irgendwem so
nun freue ich mich ehrlich auf eure
Kommentare guckt doch auch mal in die
anderen Videos meiner Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von Inside politics ihr findet
uns übrigens auch in der ZDF Mediathek